I know Kevin loves the Philadelphia
Eagles football team for us I know this
because my nanny is obsessed with the
Philadelphia ball team yes told me we
all saw him on the field after they won
the Super Bowl yes we have some photos
well there's one player celebrating with
the trophy and another up and here's
where you are yeah yeah Gertie would not
let you up yeah yeah well I have a
surprise I remembered a know what I have
a surprise the Eagles wanted to make it
up to you what do they do well it's
through those doors right up there Kim
[Applause]
[Applause]
really good friend of mine can't talk
because you know he's an eagle yeah I
mean he came all the way from Philly
choosing Kevin Superbowl cufflinks and
[Applause]
willows swoops friends also sent along a
message for Kevin take a look let me see
hey Kevin it's Brandon ground with the
Philadelphia Eagles just want to let you
know that we're over here thinking about
you and we hope that you're feeling
better after we heard you was going on
Kelly's show we knew we had to do
something so I sent my man swooped over
to surprise you we know how big of a
Eagles fan you are yes sir we sent you a
four uniform that you can wear on game
days by the way I hope it fits
let me got your measurements from Dwayne
hey I hope you're feeling better and see
you soon
hi Kelly go Birds
[Applause]
but hey this is actual confetti and they
signed it no this the sad part is that
this is my size I I know you guys think
it's a joke but this is really my size
this is this is a great thing
hey I appreciate this man I know it was
tough for you to get down here you know
what your boy flies he gave me some man
oh I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this